enseña una defensa pública la libertad
de prensa el presidente de méxico andrés
manuel lópez obrador en su alocución
matinal nuestro solidaridad y protección
con la periodista azucena urestí tras
recibir una amenaza de muerte
vamos a
y estar junto a ella
apoyando la protegiendo la cndh no está
sola
las palabras de lópez obrador han sido
bien recibidas por el gremio del
periodismo y van en consonancia con la
petición de protección que hacen desde
organizaciones de defensa de la libertad
de prensa reporteros sin fronteras insta
al gobierno a tomar en serio ese ataque
y reaccionar de inmediato tomando todas
las medidas de protección necesarias
quien me quiera añadir el mensaje llega
luego de que el lunes en un vídeo
difundido en redes sociales el cártel de
jalisco nueva generación mediante su
líder el mencho amenazó públicamente
aura stick desde el cartel vincularon a
la presentadora con las autodefensas a
las que acusan de estar financiadas por
el narcotráfico
lópez obrador ganó las elecciones con la
promesa de hacer cambios sustanciales en
el país entre sus objetivos estaba la
defensa de los periodistas de la
violencia criminal sin embargo méxico es
el país más mortífero del mundo para la
prensa desde 2000
141 periodistas han sido asesinados y
según la secretaria de gobernación de
méxico desde que el presidente asumió el
poder el 1 de diciembre de 2018 fueron
43 los periodistas asesinados